colin powell first black u.s secretary
of state dies of kobe 19 implications
amit cancer battle this is a cnn story
and he was fully vaccinated uh first
black u.s secretary leadership and
several republican administrations
helped shape american foreign policies
in the last years of the 20th century in
the early years of 21st century as that
complications of covey was 84 years old
and donald trump wrote to his supporters
wonderful to see colin powell who made
big mistakes on iraq and famously
so-called weapons of mass destruction be
treated in death so beautifully by the
fake news media hope that happens to me
someday he was a classic rhino
uh if even that always being the first
to attack other republicans he made
plenty of mistakes but anyway may he
rest in peace and president bush said he
was a great public servant starting with
his time as a soldier during vietnam he
was
such a favorite of presidents that he
earned the presidential medal of freedom
twice
uh two thoughts
uh what a great general we're a great
american at least he served his country
he rose up to be amazing general i
didn't serve underneath him i was in
high school i read books on um
you know the the leadership
that he
gave to our armed forces so i think he's
a great american what i think about
trump's statement
you know man politics is ugly
it's so ugly and um unfortunately some
people can't control
um
you know their emotions online but do i
support that statement
no i don't obviously i don't support i
love i i love what colin powell did for
our country and i don't support that
statement but i will tell you that um
wars are very political
and lies and deceptions are made for
for to employ soldiers overseas
so
what i'm saying is politics can get ugly
but i do not support that
that message that trump said to the
general
adam
yeah i think uh colin powell is one of
those people whether you're on the left
or the right i i'm sure that there's
going to be people that disagree but you
look at him and just say wow like what a
what an admirable man
sure he didn't get everything right
and i know that towards the end he
definitely didn't align himself with the
republican party especially trump so
shocker alert
trump's talking crap about a
dead general uh i i don't think anyone
didn't see that one coming but as an
american
i think you can always look at colin
powell and say that's
that's what america is about he you know
came from a family of immigrants like
yourself like yourself
served in the in the army um
medal of presidential medal of freedom
twice
uh and may he rest in peace
yeah i don't think a lot of people know
his story did he know you talked about
dealing with your racism
nobody talked to him at west point for
four years
he was in west point nobody spoke to him
for four years
not a word not a single word until his
graduation he didn't quit
he didn't he didn't turn code he didn't
say screw this i would have been out
listen to hell with this
nobody spoke to the man
they didn't look at him for his first
year and he stuck through it i had lunch
with him once an incredibly powerful
powerful powerful figure disagreed with
with foreign policy i hate the bush
doctrine i don't think we should have
been in these places i think we're just
now seeing the fallout of the bush
doctrine i think it was a you know a
post-cold war
trying to donald rumsfeld and dick
cheney i can write a whole book on how
these these guys were evil in my eyes
and and i think h.l mankind said that
war is the logical conclusion of
politics and guys like cheney and
rumsfeld never had to go overseas but
they sent a lot of people over there and
i can't stand that um colin powell said
to me you know i met him i was playing
with the newark bears at the end of my
my only career and he goes uh
you know
when you're when your career is done you
should you should go on to the service
and i was like man i don't i don't know
if that's what i'm doing he goes that's
a shame we can use guys like you and
that was a really really powerful thing
i i it's to this day my biggest single
regret is that when baseball was already
and go immediately into the service how
old are you right now 35. it's not too
late
i got three
i don't know if i can run the miles
though
that would be that would be the struggle
but hey look they keep uh they keep
lowering the the standards i don't know
you know maybe i can identify as a as a
tree and not have to run at all i don't
know we'll see what happens
made the man rest in peace
uh and ever a chance to meet with them
or speak with them or have any
interactions with them and real quick
pat before we move on this should put to
rest that whole conversation that we had
three podcasts ago about desantis
running or not
if it that that's not presidential
you know to to attack a guy who served
his country not a fan of that i don't
know why i mean that's i don't know what
that is
is like the least breaking news ever
this is
i'm not a fan of that but at the flip
side he said he's right politics is ugly
and dirty
you know god
when trump dies what do you think the
left's going to say when he dies
what do you think about an admirable man
yeah okay so when you when that's he's
not doing anything to change it yeah no
he's not doing anything to change it but
at the same time like this comment
mccain comment these are not comments
that are
what part of that comment gets support
though yeah like if you're trying to
flip anybody okay tell me how that
flipped anybody it's too petty first
they said there's two perfect people
right there's two people like
minus a handful of people but the unborn
and the dead man just leave those two
alone it's dead they can't do nothing
they can't argue with you the argument
is over with move on so anyways it is
what it is may the man rest in peace so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]